[Music]
how's everyone doing nice it's two
o'clock we're ready right my name is
Aaron I'm the director of product
management in data analytics
organization in Google clouds and today
I have my guest Michelle she will join
us in a few seconds if you want you can
come up here to yeah and today's topic
is data governance in this world and
we've got a lot of questions yesterday
even during my presentation for
streaming analytics whenever you have
asked I think you're there thank you
I love that topic this is something
we're gonna talk about probably at
length over the years but I want to
start what we're gonna discuss today and
Michelle is gonna color a lot of insight
for you guys I'm really excited to have
her here with us and we're gonna talk
about what data governance is what
companies are doing in the end I'm gonna
little cover about what we're doing on
Google clouds to help you really deal
with your world and how these things can
be actually enabling capabilities to
grow your businesses so let's talk about
data data is getting bigger and bigger I
think I mentioned this yesterday too
by 2020 every one of us in the world
every second will produce about two
megabits of data every second that's a
lot of data sum them up there's about 88
billion of us that's quite a bit of them
look at look at all those things that
we're seeing today their business is
being built around this but still we're
scratching the surface of what we can do
with data either we're not ready either
we're afraid of it or we don't have the
right choice for it who remembers the
v's of the data the big data remember
velocity variety volume those three
things are still kicking really really
high take a look at the volume and
variety
it's tripling
fantastic for us because you can take
this data and great generate some great
insights for your businesses but if
you're not prepared to deal with it that
won't help you look at the velocity it
is shaping up immensely yesterday we
talked about streaming and I had a
partner on stage with me Amy tasted they
were talking about how they were
utilizing this real-time data to
generate revenues for their customers
you can do the same if you can harness
how we can use the data if you can turn
governance into revenue generating
mechanism for yourself we are seeing
businesses building data and
event-driven structures for themselves
you can do the same we have the platform
for you we have the means for you there
are a lot of things that we're learning
but I said we're not really using all
the data available enhance take a look
at this only 1% of the unstructured data
is in use only 1% if you look at the 50%
of the structured data is still sitting
and not being used for decision-making
we're leaving it we're leaving value
behind us what will it take for us to
really get there I think all of us know
why we can't do this right it's complex
say there's distributed everywhere lots
of legacy applications silos we may not
have the talents but there's still awake
what do you think well we have to
address people I know we have to address
people what do we really want we want to
be able to use it we want to be able to
interact with it we want to be able to
play with our data but our experience
around our data is really we struggle
with it we struggle with it on a small
data scale and if we struggle it with it
there we're gonna struggle with it on a
big data scale who owns the data
all right let's some guesses it has to
be interactive who owns the data
well the data
all right that's one way collective okay
do you own your data yeah
company owns the data these are way
better answers than what I usually get
we have smart Googlers in the room um
few years ago we started asking the
question who owns the data looking at it
through the lens of saying where's the
data strategy sit where does governance
it where does master data management sit
all things that help us better
understand and take advantage of our
information to make decisions to grow
our revenues to create great customer
experiences and data decision-makers
what did they say
IT owns it 50% of them I take take care
of it losing I see here you own the data
do you want to own the data no so what
do we do so that was back in 2015 and
2018 we asked the question again and
what did the data systems makers say
they said Iced he still owns it and more
of them said that IT owns it so what
does that actually mean I mean you said
who created it where does it come from
who's you know who's taking care of it
and it really boils down to this I want
my data to work stop frustrating me
every time I go into my application
every time I go into my business
intelligence every time I'm trying to
run analytics every time I'm just trying
to figure out who my customer is so I
can have a grand old party right so lock
your data don't make it work for you and
when they talk about or when our
respondents talked about IT owns the
data it's because the complexity of it
is a nightmare it's what we deal with
every day we need to simplify it so what
we're gonna do is now take this to data
governance because data governance
really is
that accelerator to make it happen do
you believe that and she will convince
you guys yeah how data governance isn't
accelerated for the business seller
radar so let's introduce you to data
governance first there we go
so if you look at data governance little
history go back some of you are coming
from the very highly regulated
industries back in 2007 it was specific
to the department's very specific in
2008 if you remember there was this
crisis
lots of regulation around the financial
data what can be done who can be done
very prescriptive remember those days
things have changed but if you look at
today where we are GDP our happens right
in Europe in here this EPA is happening
don't be afraid of it it's actually
going to help you make more sense from
your data what's driving the governance
in the data governance in the
initiatives we want to connect to our
customers see who they are get a
customer 360 we want to control our data
protect ourselves stay in compliance we
know that our regulators look at how we
use data and the type of data that we're
collecting to say how we're doing um you
know we just don't feel like we're in
control let's that make that data work
thing we don't have great experiences
how can we trust our information to make
decisions every one of them are actually
asking about these things the complexity
of the data lack of control that's or
maybe the perception of control and how
we can actually operational drive
efficiency around it and risk management
these are all items that are driving the
governance needs now it is about policy
it's about people it's about technology
now you might say hey I heard the same
thing for other things too but it's
absolutely true but there are specific
cases that we can actually leverage and
build together to really make this thing
work for you it is going to be driving
the success how does it come to rescue
well
data governance is like any other
competency and practice in our business
people process technology sounds really
boring on the surface of it but it's
that brain trust that comes together
we're not only are you trying to drive
down the the complexity whether you're
trying to mitigate risk but on the other
hand we do have strategies of getting
value from our data and we need policies
that enable us to democratize it and to
find those great insights and so when we
talk about data governance as that
starting point for that value and
accelerating our business forward that's
how we should really be thinking about
our governance program it's a strategic
competency it's not just have you seen
examples of people who operationalize
this what does this thing well these
days so I think John Deere has done some
really interesting things anyone in here
in the world of where John Deere is
similar to some of manufacturing
operations well maybe they will take it
though all right let's tell a little bit
of story about this just like every
other company here all of you here
governance is a nightmare
and when we've started on big data and
predictive and prescriptive analytics we
don't want anything getting in our way
so what do we do we grab the data we
need and we start analyzing it and we
build insights this is what john deere
was really focused on how do we help
farming communities drive better crop
yields how do we better manage the
finances around crop insurance for
example and so they were just grabbing
all of this IOT data off of their
tractors watching how those tractors
were operating in the fields how the
seeds and the fertilizer was going how
the harvesting was happening relating
this all back to their customers and the
finances to support this as well as the
dealerships who are hoping with a lot of
the fixes on the equipment
um what happens though they ran into a
problem they were thinking about
governance they weren't thinking about
what is the org structure of themselves
in order to relate back to their
customers and dealerships they didn't
have the proper master data around their
customers and their dealerships so you
can think about how do you create all
these relationships and really
understand what information can I share
or should I share with whom there are
things that agronomists don't want to
share what the dealerships or they don't
want to share with their banks it's very
personal and when you move equipment
around in big farming areas what happens
they don't just tracked her down the
street you're not always stuck behind
the International Harvester
sometimes I put on flatbeds and they
move what happens when you move that
tractor 50 miles and you're trying to
figure out how your harvest is going
that's a problem so a lot of data
quality issues were starting to come up
so what they really did is they took a
look at how they were moving forward
very quickly they were running a DevOps
agile development practice not thinking
about governance as requirements now
they start to bring those business
requirements in that really drive the
policies the understanding about who
their customers are who their
dealerships are who they are as an org
understanding how their equipment runs
and it's not just this control thing
that drives you away but it actually
brings the value back in and so rather
than struggling for another year with
these practices they're able to really
drive forward very very quickly because
the information is trusted and the value
of the insights really be together this
is why we wanted to share some of these
examples with you early on because if
you're on this path and start actually
looking at it down the road you'll start
seeing hey we didn't really think about
this it's best to really consider what
we need to do collectively as you're
building your operations around data
around events and what you want to do
around big data because governance is
gonna be your guide your governance is
gonna be your help it's gonna be there
to really
help you excel some of the things that
are coming in your way that you may not
be concerning it today so how do you
start to look at this well you want to
have a vision for the future you want a
success story you want to know what
success looks like so let's connect the
dots between what information that we
have does it matter which industry the
industry no difference no difference
they may not be farmers in here you
don't have to be a farmer okay good you
don't have to be a mechanic okay you
don't have to be an engineer
you could be all of those things but
they have supply chains they have supply
chains they run they do they've got
financial systems it's your business it
doesn't matter and everybody has a
vision for where their business should
go and what those objectives are so
build your success story around that
start with where are my business
opportunities how is data gonna shape
that for me where do I want to take my
business forward John Deere's example
there is to push the envelope on not
just being a farming equipment company
they want to help you do a better job at
bringing products to market them
yourself and recognizing being real
about the challenges that you face not
just that you're missing information but
really holistically looking at how you
interact and engage with that data and
how you're going to put it to use look
at the people and processes the
experiences around that data from the
point of bringing it into the point of
where it's being presented to the point
where you're making decisions and taking
actions off of that now you can start
looking at a much more holistic solution
for your data strategies overall for the
management of that and taking into
account the governance policies that are
going to happen from it and then it
boils down to how do I know I did a
great job
how do I sell myself how do I tell that
story how do I get that next promotion
it's what I do great from a data
management perspective what did I do
great from a data governance perspective
and what did I do great from a business
perspective so you have three different
points of view for every stakeholder
that
is part of delivering value and 69
percent of companies who do this who
think from a business lead perspective
have data governance and programs have
data governance programs in place so
that doesn't look like putting the
brakes on your business does it they
have grown and the way that you start to
enable and drive culture change around
that is how do you know the data is good
where do you put in these cues as you
bring data in as you're going to use it
as you distribute that out to your
customers you're looking at social
mechanisms that say I like my data and
you see the thumbs up you see a star
that says it's certified and it's
managed and it's governed well so I know
somebody's taking a look at it and has a
vested interest in my personal ups and
my personal success
with the data and there's also accused
from a governance perspective to say are
we hitting up against any regulations
are there risks from our data so really
thinking holistically around those
success factors and metrics and KPIs and
bringing that back into the experience
to drive in appropriate culture around
that no more reactive much more
proactive approach exactly no roles and
responsibilities often times we think of
governance as you know the big
bureaucracy at the top and we have our
executive councils and there's a lot of
conversation and then you say what
happens well now I'm gonna go fix the
data but really what we're doing is
driving a hub-and-spoke culture around
this having centers of gravity where
expertise about the data and the value
from the data is going to come in and
even looking at that directly at the
endpoints of your organization when you
said who's creating the data they're
stewards and custodians not just
creationists they have a vested
responsibility in ensuring that the
information that they're collecting and
bringing in not only works for them but
will also help drive things and continue
to pay it forward to the rest of the
organization so when we talk about the
experience of data and making data work
don't forget to your end-users don't
forget the fact that nobody likes to
jump through 17 different applications
to figure out how to provide customer
support when somebody's got a problem
with their insurance policy and needs
questions answered and oh by the way
I've been through that process which is
why I explained it that way and when
you're a data scientist and you want to
go in and grab data and manipulate it
and prepare it that's great information
and insight for the data teams coming
back where they have to now interpret
and deploy those models and rationalize
them against policies so building a
mechanism for tribal knowledge to come
through is what we talk about when we
say a change in culture and bringing
data governance to the edge of your
business
now what happens you need an awesome
delivery team to do that
who's gonna instrument across
infrastructure your data sources and
your endpoints from applications to
devices to automation
we need engineering and data ops right
within our chief data office they are
the masters of delivery building the
services and the pipelines that are
going to deliver taking just like John
Deere did those data governance
requirements and data requirements
mashing them together and really
thinking succinctly about where that
drives into the solutions that happen
the chief data officer that you saw is a
trend if you look at the next 18 months
last 18 months that there's a huge tick
and you're gonna actually see that
continuing because everybody is trying
to figure out what their data strategy
is and you're trying to build their
organization around it and each of those
chief data officer czar coming with the
mindset of okay what do I do to get more
value out of my data that's exactly the
organization they're trying to establish
I am willing to bet some of you are
already in those organizations today
exactly and you need that strategic
leader because the complexity around
this not only in terms of what you want
to aspire to with your data but how you
operationalize that not just from team
and delivery but holistically your
program has to come out look at all
these different processes that are
driving towards outcomes managing around
both offensive and defensive
responsibilities taking into account
today more and more especially as gdpr
and CCPA have come on and security
breaches are you know at record levels
security is brought into the fold
it doesn't just sit over here anymore
when you're moving into more complex
data science and artificial intelligence
capabilities
you are now tapping into historical
archives of your data turning cold
storage into hot storage what is the
life cycle of that sitting there do you
actually know the lineage of your data
do you know if you can actually use that
data do you have the process to identify
all those exactly and so creating those
policies recognizing what they are
communicating them training the
organization to do that all these
different policies are resolving
themselves around those outcomes and
objectives that you're looking at both
from a data governance point of view as
well as your business policies as well
as regulatory and risk management did
you see some instances where some good
dynamic policy investments and companies
are really actually integrating into
their business practices I think the oil
and gas industry is amazing in the way
that they think about this
it's very complicated on on drawing oil
out of the ground so if you think about
the complexity of their partner
ecosystem to just build you know build
the drill to put down the well and then
run all of the the management and
maintenance off of that handling
inventory and parts you know they really
operationalize the data to the tasks and
so those policies have to balance
against things like trusted Network
to share information ensuring that parts
aren't coming from the black market and
really are too speck in here they've
purchased from so they don't have a
drill go down and lose a million dollars
an hour so you can really see where
policies business policies risk policies
are all brought together just to bring
oil to market or energy I mean energy
the same thing if you're on electric
cars exactly
so policies are really coming together
in that manner to how do you deal with
the complexity oh my goodness Wow Tech's
gotta take care of it somehow someway
without giving you too much credence I
mean you kind of need a Google at the
center of your your of your environment
and why do I say that
we think of data and how you manage it
around this notion of metadata yeah how
do we describe our information how do we
set policies around that information how
do we see ownership for that data and
and where is it located what's the
lineage of our your data assets yeah
it's just yeah you you the first thing
we do is profile our information and
capture all of that metadata what does
that metadata mean for us though is the
bigger question and so then our
governance processes come in and what do
we do we slap a glossary on top of it so
that we put it into business context now
we got an awesome data governance
program where data governance and data
management are all coming together and
we'll figure out how to connect all of
our systems and make our services and
pipelines flow and we should be often
running to the you know races and we're
all set but in the world where we have
to change the experience
we're democratizing data is much more
important than it was in the past where
data engineers don't stop at bringing
data into a data Lake or into another
type of repository but they have to
think about that delivery they have to
think about presentation of information
you need a marketplace what does that
market
look like so catalogs today start to
become that center of the universe of
not just describing the physical logical
and semantic aspects of the data not
just housing all of those policies and
ownerships and practices but also
becoming that point both from services
as well as direct access to information
so that you have and I hate to say it
we're back to a knowledge center guys
don't twitch if you remember aloneness
it's so much smarter because machine
learning is at the heart of it so all
the social cues that we talked about
earlier you can see what people are
sharing you can see what people like you
can see what people are changing you can
see what people are saying about
information and that's not just on the
consumption side that's your governance
teams and that's your data management
and engineering teams as well
so it's really important to think about
how do you bring together the metadata
facet the business glossary facet and
the marketplace and engagement and build
services that are not just about an ETL
job or a streaming job but look at the
queries that are running against your
information look at the Python and our
scripts that are coming out of your data
science notebooks all of that
information really helps you understand
not only what data you have and how it
can be used but where it's providing
value and this is my English muffinz
slide I like talking about the nooks and
crannies of where data lives don't just
think that that metadata is only in your
databases it's everywhere how are you
managed let's go back to the John Deere
situation how do you manage master data
is that in an MDM environment it could
be a Kafka topic now you're distributing
all of these definitions and models
about your data across every piece of
technology your catalogs have to be able
to profile and understand and interpret
and synchronize that
information it's really critical this is
how you can navigate your fabrics this
is how you have the appropriate
oversight don't just think about your
apps and what is following through think
about the assets think about the
containers that you're managing think
about all the servers that your data
might be running through it's we really
have to consider all that in your system
get started with it on a smaller basis
think about your solution think about
the pipeline first begin there so that
you're continuously accumulating this
information and starting to I don't know
if you're any gamers in the room you
know when you've got your game map open
and it's all highlighted and you see a
big light and the section of the map
that you're in in your universe and then
as you move around it's the map starts
to open up ok not a lot of gamers here
no no no sorry but everything becomes
illuminated as you kind of move through
and that's what your your catalogues
should be able to do and help you with
it should start illuminating iteratively
through your data ecosystems lessons
learned
one size does not fit all it is your
data has to fit the experience and the
policies and procedures and culture of
your organization it can drive massive
benefits when you tie it to those
business incomes and incomes outcomes
hopefully driving income to deliver
there is a certain amount of
centralization in the organization that
is required somebody needs to have an ID
you know has a purview over the entire
landscape that's really where that chief
data officer comes in and drives some of
the top-down priorities and objectives
for your data as well as you know making
sure that the bottom up is orchestrated
appropriately that's a tough job it's
complex from an Operations perspective
as well as from the data perspective it
requires that different approach to
empower the enterprise that notion of
tribal knowledge and tribal contribution
get that governance and culture out into
the edge and bring that back in and
that'll be multiple tools don't be
really locked in so I gotta have one
tool that does everything there are only
multiple services that you're gonna put
together
think about the flexibility try to solve
it around the problem that you have in
hands pull one thread all the way out
see what we can actually do exactly and
so measure it based off of the IT
objectives the governance objectives and
the business objectives and that's
ensuring that you're striking the right
balance between what does the value of
your data is bringing as well as
protecting you on the back end from risk
and don't think governance as compliance
only it's an enabler for you what you're
gonna be do doing with those
capabilities for your business a few
things we're doing today on Google we
are we actually announced just about all
these things so I can talk about it now
some of you may have been using our
cloud dlp services nobody ready or data
is you heard about our programs
yesterday anthos and you can actually
use it on your own prem hybrid
facilities or in GCP this is your data
loss prevention this is a fantastic tool
for those of you who are concerned about
masking the data it should not be seen
by others you can actually train it
you've been possibly using it today we
announced our metadata management cloud
data catalog this is a capability that
actually helps for you to discover your
assets metadata wherever your data might
be and it's a capability that you can
integrate with other tools that are
available outside it might be on Prem
tools that you're using through the data
metadata exchange that you can actually
achieve some of these things these are
all there for you to discover on top of
it you can build some policy management
systems access control systems that you
can build you have an integrated
identity access management that I am
sure many of you have been using it
already today that helps you identify
create
those policies types of personas who can
have what type of data access where and
when and how long these are all things
that you can do today we have a very
aggressive roadmap to really drive what
we can help you with there's a lot of
things that we can provide you around
the principles of who can access to what
data many of you have come to us and
said hey I'm dealing with this thing and
here are my PII data I don't want anyone
in my organization to have access but I
want my analysts to be able to do it but
just mask that data because it has PII
data I don't want to lose that side of
that but only those people who have
access can actually control it so we're
providing those capabilities and there's
of course their table levels there's of
course the role levels there's a lot of
things in here there's retention
policies that you wanna run or deletion
policies that you want to run those are
all part of our roadmaps that we're
talking about in here and we will be
able to really provide you
administrative tools that helps you give
gives you knobs that you can actually
provide solutions within your
organization's because you need those to
be able to drive your policies within
your organization around your business
just as it's best for you
[Music]